bron samedi soir une équipe de police
est prise à partie poubelles et voitures
incendiés tirs de mortier et feu
d'artifice une troisième nuit de
violences pour la métropole lyonnaise
bilan cinq interpellations le préfet
délégué pour la défense et la sécurité
dénonce des jeunes venus casser du flic
tous les soirs en ce moment
au delà des incendies de voitures
l'objectif c'est de prendre à partie les
policiers
éventuellement les pompiers donc là
aussi on s'attend à être caillassé ce
soir il ya plusieurs petits groupes
d'individus qui ont tenté de s'en
prendre à la police
une nouvelle fois la présence des forces
de l'ordre a permis de limiter ces
exactions ne laisse pas rien passé on
n'accepte pas les actes de violence on
n'accepte pas ce climat malsain et nous
serons présents pour tenter d'empêcher
tout ça la veille c'est la commune de
rillieux la pape qui avait été le
théâtre de violences
des actes de vandalisme perpétrés par un
peu plus d'une trentaine de jeunes six
personnes sont interpellées tandis que
le maire de rillieux la pape est la
cible de menaces de mort j'ai été de
nouveau menacé de décapitation
bien entendu je porterai plainte pour
ces faits intolérables
je ne baisserai jamais les yeux face à
ces délinquants dont la place n'est plus
dans nos rues mais en prison
à l'origine de ces affrontements un
incident de scooter mercredi qui met le
feu aux poudres dans le quartier
lyonnais de la duchère un adolescent de
13 ans qui roulait sans casque est
gravement blessé selon des jeunes du
quartier il était poursuivi par une
voiture de police banalisée en
représailles un groupe de jeunes s'en
est pris aux forces de l'ordre
enclenchant cette série de
confrontations avec la police selon le
ministre de l'intérieur les opérations
policières anti drogue visant à
démanteler les trafics de la métropole
serait à l'origine de ces tensions
s'il ya des violences urbaines s'il ya
des voitures qui peuvent brûler des
policiers qui sont pris à partie des
élus menacée c'est parce qu'avec les
polices municipales mais avec la police
nationale en premier lieu on intervient
on démantèle chaque jour des points de
deal plus il y aura harcèlement de ses
points de deal plus il ya manifestement
réaction des dealers mais à la fin ce
sera toujours la police qui va gagner
pour l'heure gérald darmanin a annoncé
un bilan total de 21 une interpellation
dans l'agglomération lyonnaise dont une
majorité de mineurs
le ministre de l'intérieur qui a annoncé
l'envoi de 200 policiers en renfort dans
la zone pour prévenir une escalade des
violences